bonjour jean luc addor merci bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct sur rt france expliquez-nous
la suisse serait-elle un peu envieuse du
breakbeat il y aurait des accords
commerciaux qui serait favorable en tout
cas à la grande bretagne que la suisse
n'aurait pas expliqué nous le contexte
l'histoire des relations entre la suisse
et l'union européenne sait c'est
justement contrairement à ce qu'elle
était le cas évidemment de dupin grande
bretagne s'est pas l'adhésion mais
c'était tout un arsenal si on veut dire
est d'accord le bilatéraux et puis il se
passe maintenant un petit peu comme si
l'union européenne étaient fatigués de
négocier tant qu'elle veut nouer la
gerbe si j'ose dire de tous ces accords
avec ce qu'on avait un accord cadre
institutionnel qui comporte toute une
série d' atteinte à l'autonomie
législative de la suisse dans des
domaines centraux
qu'ils s'agissent justement pas la
politique économique et le transport de
politiques agricoles d'immigration
régulation du marché du travail l'accès
aux assurances sociales ou encore de
droite populaire avec à la clé vous en
avez parler justement une clause alors
qu'il prévoit
à nice mme d'arbitrage mais qui en
réalité prévoir au bout du compte quand
même que c'est la cour de justice de
l'union européenne qui tranche et
effectivement nous avons observé avec
beaucoup d'attention et d'intérêt
la manière dont les britanniques ont
négocié est de plus en plus de voix
s'élèvent en suisse pour exiger la
renégociation d'un accord l'accord
coloniale j'ai j'en ai parlé d'un accord
que l'union européenne pour l'instant ne
veut être négocié mais la solution
l'isu qui tient la corde si j'ose dire
c'est que si l'union européenne sauf
steen un paolo renégocier ce qui risque
de se passer c'est que tout simplement
la suisse ne ratifie rabat cet accord ça
veut dire finalement que que les suisse
que les suisses sont envieux finalement
de ces britanniques qui aujourd'hui
finalement sont davantage libéré de
l'union européenne c'est ce que demont
et suisse aujourd'hui plus de liberté
dans leurs relations par rapport à
l'union européenne
exactement ce que nous demandons c'est
finalement de pouvoir être considérée
non pas comme un pays sujet mais comme
un vrai partenaire
c'est d'ailleurs l'idée de douces et de
tous ses accords bilatéraux et c'est la
vie que de les accorder ces ensembles
d'accord c'est enfin un phénomène vivant
il est normal que parfois il faille les
renégocier parce que les situations
changent lentement s'aperçoivent qu'un
accord nous est défavorable parfois
c'était favorable à la partie adverse
c'est ce que l'union européenne ne veut
plus faire et bien lui aussi nous
imposer des mécanismes de plus en plus
simple
d'acceptation automatique dont 3 sur
lequel nous n'avons pas prises le droit
européen est simple beaucoup d'autres
nous c'est inacceptable et puis à une
conjonction d'une page moi je dirais de
souverainistes comme commune et c'est
j'en fais partie mais également de tous
ceux qui défendent les travailleurs de
ce pays aussi les entreprises mais les
travailleurs de ce pays qui craignent
entre autres cette forme de dumping
salarial et puis cette conjonction elle
existait déjà mais c'est vrai que le
phénomène s'est renforcée quand on a vu
ce que les zambiens ont obtenu on essaye
de nous faire croire qu'on peut pas
négocier avec l'union européenne les
britanniques viennent de nous montrer le
linge est finalement du coup ils vous
ont donné des arguments avec ce break
zut alors que se passerait-il si cet
accord-cadre n'était pas signée est ce
que ça voudrait dire qu'on repartirait
dans nos négociations comme on a vu que
c'était le cas avec les britanniques des
droits de douane plus cher qu'elle sur
les implications de cette non signature
de cet accord cadre et dernière question
sur les vaccins aussi que qu'on était de
la suisse est ce que vous êtes empêtré
dans ses retards européen ou pas bon
alors si on signait pas cet accord
institutionnel
il se passerait rien d'extrêmement grave
il se passerait simplement que qu'il
faudrait se remettre
effectivement à la table des
négociations les négociations seraient
certainement dur mais l'expérience des
pique niques à montrer que contrairement
à ce qu'on nous fait asseoir nous faire
quoi il est possible de négocier avec
l'union européenne
elle peut être qu'il faut montrer les
dents c'est ce que vous ne pourrez pas
nous sommes
affaire évidemment j'ai bon espoir
qu'avec un peu de bonne volonté
eh bien on arrive à trouver un accord
qui sont pas un accord que de galles
mais qui sort un accord qui pourrait
être conclu entre des partenaires et qui
n'est pas pour conséquence la suggestion
de la suisse ni de livrer nos
travailleurs sont sans protection à une
forme de dumping salarial
maintenant la question du vaccin on a eu
certains star il faut qu'un on a bien
constaté que les côtés de m ministère de
la santé si j'ose dire à l'officiel de
la santé publique en particulier
eh bien il ya eu certaines formes d
organisation qui ont fait qu'il ya eu
certain god of 7 ans passe aujourd'hui
d'être corrigés puisqu'on nous annonce
l'arrivée imminente de bien assez de
vaccins pour vacciner tous ceux dans ce
pays qui souhaitent se faire vacciner
vous faites partie du process européen
ou pas dans la vaccination très court
oui ou non non non à la nation
tout le monde est allé un peu en ordre
dispersé c'était le cas merci beaucoup
jean luc addor merci d'avoir répondu ce
matin en direct à nos questions sur arte
france